welcome to LED live today and the big
question that we're going to be
discussing is what is the effect of the
LGBT initiative and its effect on the
church find out on this episode of LED
live right so I want to start off by
showing you a testimony about a young
woman named Emily and what I really like
about Emily's presentation is she talks
about her freedoms and her understanding
about her feelings and attractions and
then how God kind of brought in this
confusion and and how he brought her
around and changed her thinking so I
just want to share that with you now I
[Applause]
was 15 and I started dating a girl that
lived down the street from me it was my
first time ever dating someone and being
official I was pretty pumped
I got a hickey my dad saw it and was
livid I love her it's a girl and I'm
gonna be with her and this is how it is
yeah it went terribly
I guess she told some people and so they
came to me and asked me are you and her
gay together either Calloway or I can
own it so I'm gonna own it
I said yeah what about it love is not
necessarily between a man and a woman
the problem was backwards thinking and
if you were truly a Christian you were
on my side and if not you were
legalistic and you needed to reread what
God was really about judge not God being
loved met God was nice and God was
chilled with what you call with by 18
and 19 and 20 I was super wild and
serial relationships with women when I
got some nursing school I met the girl
that I ended up being engaged to I kind
of slowed down a little bit for her
because she had two kids and then at 22
I got invited to a Bible City I expected
them to bring up my lifestyle really
early and then would use that as
justification for not coming back so I
agreed to go different women in the
circle who are talking about different
experiences they had I have nothing like
that and it bugged me
I could not stop thinking what if all
that's true are you sure this is who you
are
[Applause]
I couldn't stop questioning
I need to feel okay because I don't feel
okay anymore
I googled verses on homosexuality those
who practice homosexuality which was me
and also drunkards and a bunch of other
things that I would have been I realized
that I was in the will I enter the
kingdom of God lineup and it scared me
really really bad and then I read verse
11 and it says and such were some of you
but you were washed you were sanctified
you were justified I realized that there
are people in the same place and they
were saved and they were changed and
that God could do that for me too and
that I needed that
I could hold onto my sin and reject God
or I could turn to him all the debt that
I'd racked up living like I lived didn't
have to be mine if I could trust him so
that was it I knew what I wasn't gonna
do because it was right there it's black
and white I twisted those scriptures
before I daren't get them down
I said judge not to them like that
mattered and then that day it was like
my eyes were really opened I was amazed
at the grace he'd shown me people say to
me all the time I was born this way I
said okay yeah me too you're not born
with wrought affections that's why Jesus
had to come you feeling a desire for sin
just proves you need grace like me it's
not gay to straight it's lost to saved
God calls us not to heterosexuality but
the holiness even though the world would
paint a totally different story about
what sexuality is and isn't God's Word
is clear and he can save and he does and
he will
[Music]
isn't that amazing
what I've really really emphasized on
this is that God's Word is true and he
can save and he does save and he will
say and I think for for me that was
really difficult coming into church
culture after 20 years of living as a
homosexual and a sex addict for me what
was on my mind is that it was all
focused on me not only what I have done
and who I have created and become but it
was also about that I was the one that
had to change so I forgot or I didn't
forget I just didn't know that it was
God that had to do the changing because
I could never change
you know we have this phrase that God
didn't say stop being gay he just said
stop resisting me and in that process of
learning how to first of all be honest
and transparent about what I was going
through but then as God was unpacking
all the history in the memory then he
started to give me new thoughts and new
feelings and new desires that I didn't
even think we're possible
and of course on my own I could never
create that but that's what I kept
spinning before I was 20 years old
thinking that I had to change that I had
to be straight when the focus wasn't
about being straight the focus was about
following Jesus Christ and so I think
that Emily does an excellent job of
pointing out that that she said that was
it I was I knew what I what I wasn't
going to do and that was like so
poignant to me the turnaround for her
it's like okay his word is clear and
then I just love I just love how like
she started to experience change and the
process of how she found that I remember
when I got baptized my boyfriend brought
me to the to the gay church and I went
there occasionally so that engage her
yeah yes it's the Unitarian Church so I
remember that the pastor there was a
woman and she just you know went through
all of the different verses in the Bible
about homosexuality and she basically
explained them all away at that point in
my Christian walk I was only following
Jesus Christ it wasn't a denominational
thing but my boyfriend was there
dragging me to the Gator trying to get
me you know to reason again back to my
old way of thinking but
the pastor just kept making these
exceptions for this behavior and even in
my limited understanding being a
hairdresser and of course I never read
the Bible I would look at her to go that
don't even make sense like her whole her
whole thing about Sodom and Gomorrah was
that it was the sin of in hospitality
what they put their fork on the wrong
side of the plate what is she talking
about and so now that you know now that
I know the Bible a little bit more I can
go to Jude and I realized in Jude it's
very plain it says the problem with
sodom and gomorrah was sexual immorality
and while that's not explicitly or only
homosexuality
it certainly is inclusive to it and so I
started to understand better about that
so a coming up ministry but before you
move on yeah I found it I love that the
testimony was profound for sure and she
was referencing first Corinthians
chapter 6 I think a lot of times people
make the mistake of stopping they don't
read straight through but she kept on
reading after Paul goes to all this list
of of immoral things verse 11 and such
were some of you is what she was
referencing in the video but you were
washed and you are sanctified and you
are justified in the name of Jesus the
Lord Jesus and by the spirit of our God
it's not just turning away from the
lifestyle it's looking for justification
through Jesus Christ yeah and I and I
think there were a little cavalier on
that point because that was really what
was missing it's only through Jesus
Christ that you can be washed that you
can be justified and that you could be
sanctified those are three things that
man just can't do for himself and so
whatever those issues were in 1st
Corinthians chapter 6 and and
homosexuality was one of them but it was
like slander gossip thieving you know
there's a whole list that we can find
ourselves in at least one or two of
those but how sad because I really
believe that the issue that started for
the for the gay rights and and legally
or legalizing gay marriage really came
from the Christian Church because the
Christian Church was the one that I
heard they said gays can't change and
that they're gonna burn in hell and then
there was no hope for them so I think
that the gay community said all right
well if that's my future if that's who I
am that I want special rights and I want
to be you know given the ability to
marry
and so if the Christian Church was the
ones that kind of started that whole
thing now look where we are you know
several years later and I believe that
um that the answer to that is take it
back and put it back in the pot with
everything else and you know what what
it does is it kind of levels the playing
field and it takes away the
condescension of Christianity that Pat's
their head on the on the homosexual says
they're there you know God still loves
you instead it's like listen you know
you've got your issues and I've got mine
and Jesus says that he has the answer
for all of us you know I mean puts us on
the same playing field so again coming
up ministries vision is to ignite an
incredible movement restoring all men
and women back to the image of our
Creator God and and that's not a gay
thing that's a sin thing isn't it yeah
however in regards to the LGBT issue and
how it has an effect on the church I
found this this this phrase that says
religion doesn't have a prayer when it
comes to equality LGBT activists and
their judicial allies have made sure
sexual behavior Trump's religious
liberty every time and that's what we're
starting to see that as we go around the
world we're seeing that this is a global
issue it's not just something that's in
our hometown or in our local community
or in the big cities and so as I as I
really struggle with um seeing the
promotion of this somebody said to me
they go you know what Mike you really
are living in the wrong time you you
keep missing it you know 20 years when
you were coming out of the gay life of
course it wasn't popular to be gay and
you live 20 years in that culture but
now it's okay to be gay and now you're
saying that you're coming out of there
so I really missed my mark but I just
praise God that he was willing to to
pull me out of that at all but what
we're seeing now are these two
completely polarized positions when I
walked away from Jesus Christ in 1980
what was going on in the church again
was that the position that we had was
that that gays can't change and that God
hated us and so I got that message and I
walked out of church culture but then
when I came back into the church and we
started this ministry 10 years ago the
message is now is being promoted is that
oh you know God loves gays because they
can't change meaning that gays can't
change so now God loves him so therefore
if I tell gays that they have to change
or that God has
for them that's considered hate speech
so isn't interesting because the message
is still the same that can't change but
either God hated them or he loves them
and that's where we're at in the church
today but the problem is they left out
verse 11 and verse 11 says such were
some of you so when we were coming into
this ministry we thought that we were
providing hope and another option for
people that didn't necessarily know that
Jesus does love you and that Jesus can
wash and sanctify and justify each one
of us so as we began this ministry and
started moving forward we started to
realize that this was not just a gay
issue that people were coming up to us
and saying you know I'm not gay but you
were talking to me like the same steps
that God took you through he's been
taking me through as well and so we
recognized that not only do we want to
minister to those that are sexually
broken you know but we also want to
prepare the church and equip the church
so that when those people come in that
they can find a place a safety net of
not only acceptance but healing also so
to institutions that were established it
creation when in Genesis 1 27 and 28 was
the fact that God made us in His image
male and female created he them so the
fullest expression of God's image wasn't
just in Adam it was in the combination
of Adam and Eve together what that means
is that male and female together is this
complementarianism between the two and
the two of them together was the fullest
expression of God why because it was a
creative couple now if it was just Adam
alone he didn't have the power to create
or evil them but the two of them
together even the way that they're
designed God then said hey your first
work is to be fruitful and multiply and
so as God is a creative God he also
gives man the ability to create as well
the the thought that comes in my mind
about that is probably for you Keith
when you you know had your first child
and you looked into your your baby's
face and you said wow you know this baby
has my ears or or my eyes you know would
that be something that in that creative
process God gives man the distinct
ability to look into our own creation
and to see ourselves what a perfect
example of the creative power of God so
we know that the enemy's whole idea is
going to be to destroy that ability for
man to create right to take away that
gift or to take away that image the
image of God being created in male and
female together so it's interesting to
me that we know that Satan wants to be
like the Most High in Ezekiel it talks
about how he wants to sit in the right
in the sides of the North right and be
like the Most High so doesn't it make
sense that Satan if I was Lucifer I'd be
really angry if God passed me by and
gave the gift of creation to man so
doesn't it make sense that Lucifer's
focus is going to be how can I steal
this away you can steal that away
through abortion through promiscuity you
can take it away through homosexuality
LGBT and transgenderism if I destroy or
mutilate my my genitalia then I've
destroyed the gift that God has given to
me and the identity that he also created
in each one of us so the other
institution that God also created in the
garden before sin under the world was
the Sabbath day and it's interesting to
me because I think to myself if we're
under attack
under marriage which was the first
institution then is it possible that God
is watching us to see how we handle this
issue to know how we're gonna handle
Sabbath when it's under attack I don't
know that's just a thought in my head
and you know it's called the twin
institutions but then when you look at
the biology Genesis 1:27 again and and
look at the image on the screen I think
it's so elementary and you know here you
have like the different kind of sockets
and you have to you know female sockets
women and women of course you know no
power there right and two males together
you know you put them to get the no
power there but when you take the the
male and the female connector you put
them together BAM you get like power
right electricity and that's the
creative power so each of the others is
a misrepresentation of the image that
God wants in each one of us and I
believe that that's why God calls it an
abomination not because I'm an
abomination
but because the act of it misrepresents
the creative power of God
male in the female so that was really
difficult for me to understand like how
dare you call me an abomination when you
made me this way
and that was my understanding as I came
into my relationship with God but as I
started to understand better and you
look at the text God does not call me an
abomination he calls the act an
abomination and when I think about that
and an abomination is just such a
horrible word and it really shuts down
conversations between Christians and non
Christian people or LGBTQ community and
other people when you use that word but
really to me if you take out the word
abomination and instead if you supply
the phrase anything that separates the
intimacy of God from his creation and so
it doesn't have just an application to
the homosexual practice it also has
enough lies to transgenderism premarital
sex pornography lust fornication
licentiousness throw it all back in
there they're all Obama even slander and
gossip right so um that really helped me
to understand that you know we are who
we are through identity and art and it
drives our actions so it's interesting
because a new term now that's out there
is gay Christian this is my identity and
now that this is being promoted even
through Christianity a lot of Christian
churches are are basically in my opinion
they're just kind of giving in to this
as an identity it's like well you know
if it's true that you can't change then
then of course I guess you can be a gay
Christian there's a lot of oxymorons
coming nowadays you have holy yoga yeah
Christian witches and I have gay
Christians it's like you know these two
equally different sides coming together
right right
the more confusion you bring into it the
more you can muddy out the waters on on
what true Christianity is well let's use
this word for just a moment of this
phrase you know what is a prefix you
know just let me throw it out there
what's a prefix it's coming the first
part of the word first part of the way
so if I use the term gay Christian and I
use gay as my prefix on my identity in
Christ what is a prefix do to a word
you're making a prime primary right it's
like the more important but it also
changes the meaning of the second word a
prefix changes the word like re-creation
means that you're taking the creation
and you're
King it over again so if I say that I'm
a gay Christian my priority my prior are
my primary identity is gay and my second
identity is in Christ and so do you see
do you see the the conflict there no
because my identity is either in Christ
or nothing at all so when we allow that
term gay Christian and they're basing it
on the fact that some people say that
that sexuality is immutable and that it
can't change so if you're born gay then
that's just who you are and and so now
they're gonna slap that on my identity
in Christ here's the problem and I use
um I used the Bible as the as the guide
on this though I didn't say it but in
God's Word he says that homosexual
practice is not according to his plan
for us so that is also limit or that is
also listed as a sin temptation so when
you take a sin temptation and now you
slap it on your identity in Jesus Christ
now what you've done is you've
legitimized sin so first first John 1:9
says that if we confess our sins that he
is faithful and just to forgive us our
sins and cleanse us from all
unrighteousness but if I don't identify
it as a sin I'm not going to confess it
and therefore I've limited the hand of
God to not only forgive me but to
cleanse me do you see the contradictions
and you're drunk Christian or a [__]
Christian or anything oh come on now
Mike it's like look at this present day
so what's happening now is like you know
there are many there are 10 different
Commandments that we have and so you
know if I'm allowed to identify as a gay
Christian then you can identify as a
lying Christian or maybe a stealing
Christian or maybe you can be an
adulterer ating Christian right but
since we don't have those labels on any
other sin why would we permit this on
this sin unless I believe that Christian
culture many years ago was the one that
singled out the gay sin and I believe
that the gay community took that and ran
and they said okay if you're gonna
single us out then this is how we want
and I believe that what we have to do
again put it back into perspective with
all the other sin temptations that are
out there so I thought this was
interesting the gospel is meant to
change the sinner not for the sinner to
change the gospel to suit their sin yeah
the old nature born of blood and the
will of the
flesh cannot inherit the kingdom of God
the old ways the hereditary tendencies
the former habits must be given up for
Grace's not inherited the new birth
consists in having new motives new
tastes and new tendencies those who are
begotten unto a new life by the holy
spirit have become partakers of the
divine nature and in all their habits
and practices they will give evidence of
their relationship to Christ when men
who claim to be Christians retain all
their natural defects of character and
disposition and what does their position
differ from that of the worldly they do
not appreciate the truth as a Sanctifier
and a refiner they have not been born
again so when we go back to the term gay
Christian again that is basically taking
all of my old habits and my old
behaviors and my old identity and saying
that I'm going to attach that now to my
identity in Christ which in my
understanding is a contradiction of what
the gospel is designed to do you know
what I find to be really interesting
with that is that that calls for a lot
of surrender and what came to mind was
this on this quote from this book called
our higher calling and it reads never
will the human heart know happiness
until it is submitted to be molded by
the Spirit of God so as you were
mentioning with that quote it's like
sometimes even though we know this is an
issue it's really hard to now say okay
we're going to let the sin go because we
just want to hold on to it for example
you were talking about the gay Christian
like we still want to serve God in a
sense like myself I mentioned that I'd
purchased a house I was like Lord I'm
gonna have this house bless to you but
at the same time like I still want to
have these group sex these these orgy
parties like I want to have this plan so
it's like you're trying to still have
you're still trying to serve God you're
still trying to do your own thing you're
trying to have it come together but at
the end of the day as that quote had
mentioned there's no true happiness that
we're all seeking for TZ I think that's
the best explanation because I've always
been in this quandary about how you
could think that it's okay to have your
house blessed by God and talking about
all these sex parties so thank you for
that because now I start to see I
believe that the dilemma that we're
really dealing with now is that it's
okay to keep your religion before it was
like you had to be you had to leave your
religion to be heterosexual LGBT or
whereas now it's like oh it's okay you
can be spiritual you can be Christian
and bring all
that into it together as well which
makes me think of where he said I wish
you were either hot or cold not in the
middle not like more that's worse yeah
all right so now it's not just a gay
issue anymore this is the this is what's
out there now that that's also coming
into the rise
now that gay marriage is accepted and
legal now we have other groups that are
coming into the fringe that are wanting
and demanding their rights take a look
at this it is a cultural story and a
controversial one at that about an
unusual Modern Family featuring two moms
and one dad
they call it polyamory and ABC's Abby
Boudreau has more oh the sweet sounds of
mourning as a dual parent the bad you
once shared with your partner now a
little more crowded and all the more so
when there are three meet the Phoenix
times Danny Melinda and John and their
babies
Ella and Oliver form just five weeks
apart these two moms and one dad are
polyamorous so if you're not a couple
what do you call yourselves so that
blows my mind now what we're seeing
coming into even church culture and even
into Christianity is this combination of
like okay well you know I'm committed to
my partner let's bring in a third party
or or you might say that the truest
definition of a marriage to you is too
confining and so you want to bring in a
third or fourth person into your
marriage as well this is being promoted
through the media there are television
shows on cable that are dedicated and
they're called you know by their name
and now they have shows that are being
promoted also like you know fixing up
your house and decorating your house new
and and they're going to redo a house
for a family that's polyamorous so again
the more you make this normal now what
I'm starting to hear in church culture
as well as on the outside is that
couples are trying to spice up their
love life or thinking okay well maybe
I've been too narrow mind
maybe I really need to think about
including a third party into our
marriage to make it better those were
things that while I was in the gay
culture those were things that were our
freedom to do so you know because we
knew that we were outside the bounds of
Christianity but now they're actually
coming into Christian experiences I
think this is just cause more problems
it's starting to read a book on
Christian ethics and this really smacks
of a particular form of ethics called
anti no mean ism which basically boils
down to there are no rules and people
can do what's right in their own eyes
mm-hmm
you know you call it one thing but
really if you look at whatever but he's
doing it just you know it's a
free-for-all the lawless one yeah yeah
okay so that brings me to this next
point so let me give you an illustration
if if the door to my house is open just
this far and then there's like this six
foot long snake and I just opened my
door just that much just an inch how
much of that snake can get in through
the door right and so that's what's
happening the minute that we start
allowing these definitions the minute
that we give rights for marriage to to
one group outside of the bounds of what
God has established for each one of us
then all of a sudden the whole snake is
coming in the door because you know you
let one group and then all the other
groups are going to be clamoring to come
in this legal precedence that's right
that's right all of this is being
promoted by a propaganda I want to share
this with you talking about the
transgender issue this is uh this is
rape bold or not really involved what's
his name you faint book you think I'm
insane he's you saying okay so the same
boat he was the one that was like
running the Olympics and he broke all
these World Records and Jamaica or in
the Caribbean to me is very hard against
LGBT acceptance so the idea is that they
know that
can control the thoughts and the
feelings of the people through the media
so the idea is to take their hero and if
you put him in a dress and all of a
sudden you slowly start to break down
these prejudices that have been in the
Caribbean for many years take a look
famous sports icons on a planet such as
Hussein Boat who is sponsored by virgin
if this man can Electrify the planet in
a space of nine seconds and sent his
home country Jamaica into a frenzy when
he wins race many are aware that his
native island is not tolerant of the
LGBTI agenda at all so to break them
down if you just cleverly adorn their
icon in a dress it will slowly break
down any resistance only those who
understand advertising and media are
fully aware of how it works just read
every Bernays propaganda book published
in 1928 and he advised corporations to
use famous icons to promote an agenda
even if they are not fully aware of what
they are doing
holo has been doing this for a long time
yeah McDonough was interviewed by a gay
magazine back in 1984 and you know what
it was in the bars with her you know
hearing or her her music and they asked
her in this gay publication they said
how come you'd make so many references
to you know homosexuality in your videos
and she said well she said at first some
people will be disgusted by it she said
but some people be turned on and she
said the more they see it over and over
and over again eventually it'll be no
big thing and now we look at it in 2020
and see the power of what Madonna has
brought into our world culture yeah she
was absolutely right and she understood
the power of the media
absolutely what's wrong with this
picture
now I saw this picture for many years
and I thought it was incredibly
compassionate you know Jesus putting
this garment over this guy but can you
pick out what's wrong in this image okay
anyone else any other comments behind
them let me give you my simple
understanding so the problem with this
image is exactly what you said Kendi is
that Jesus is covering the man with his
dirty filthy garment still on
and so basically of course Jesus loves
us as we are but Jesus doesn't leave us
where we are each one of us no matter
what your issues were we had to make
sacrifices we had to take off our old
identities the way that we identified
ourselves and to take them off so in
this picture this guy is still wearing
his old rags and we know that our
righteousness is as filthy rags our
garment is our righteousness right so in
revelation 3:18 it says I advise of you
to buy from me gold refined by fire so
that you may become rich and white
garments so that you may clothe yourself
and I like this part and that the shame
of your nakedness will not be revealed
so it less we're naked God can't cover
us with his righteousness he's not gonna
cover our sin he wants to replace it
from our sin right so that meant I had
to take off all the ways that I
identified myself 20 years living as a
homosexual 20 years of cultivating this
as my identity I had to come to a
decision
did I want Jesus in my life or did I
want to keep my boyfriend and it was a
really difficult decision for me to make
and I don't want to minimize in any way
somebody who's really struggling and
like the day that you came to my
sister's house and Moshe were you were
struggling we're the tug of war over
your garment yeah what was so amazing is
that had Jesus not given me something
better you know I would have gone back
and Jesus not giving me something
completely different than a way that I
identified and the things that I
cultivated I wouldn't have wanted that
new garment and I think that that's what
Christianity really lacks today is that
yeah we have the truth but we bash
people over the head for the truth and
it's like oh yeah that's really inviting
I remember
marching in the gay pride parades and I
would see you know the mark the
picketers with her their signs have said
God hates [__] and thank God for AIDS
and that didn't endear me to them and
said it made me a shame that I'd ever
called myself a Christian and it pushed
me even further into the gay community
because that was my family they loved me
at least and even if it wasn't
necessarily the truth it at least felt
like a type of love and that love
compelled me to stay in there and so we
as Christians lose great advantage when
we tell the truth but we do it with a
bat you know and we bash people over the
head and that's not Invitational I
believe that the Christian Church has
lost much ground because we need to not
only take that truth we don't throw off
the truth to be loving but love is the
truest expression of that truth we have
to have both of them together mm-hmm you
know this this karma that you're talking
about what's interesting is you see the
same thing in Genesis with Adam and Eve
because they brought their own clothes
to the table and those clothes would
have had to go for them to get the
clothes that Christ provided with them
the animal skins even with that like
just having to be naked before Christ
recognizing that there's a level of
vulnerability that has to take place and
that's the scariest thing ever because
uh if you're used to having all these
these surfacing relationships and now
you have to come to a place of having a
very deep intimate patient relationship
with God it's very scary so of course
like it makes so much sense even when I
think about my own set my own self why
it took me so long to come to that place
of of saying okay I'm going to surrender
I'm going to be vulnerable to God it's
scary because now it's like okay I'm
your I have to now remove everything
that I once loved and have to be patient
and wait on God and recognize that this
journey is not going to just happen so
quickly that Boop you know I'm all
perfect all of a sudden it's recognizing
that it's a day-by-day process a process
of learning to be dependent upon Christ
and that's hard when when you know
immediate gratification even if it's
with the wrong thing but now having to
learn to wait upon God and to wait on
his promises it's hard sometimes but
it's not impossible
that's really
my song is you said that you had to make
the decision to stay with my boyfriend
or be with Christ even if some people
could give up the home of the same-sex
lifestyle or whether they transgender to
give up the whole process but they still
beat themself up because they still have
the attraction so what what do you have
to say to this ah thank you for that um
you know when I got baptized I didn't
come up out of that water straight and
ready to marry you know it wasn't holy
water
right and so as I started this
relationship with Jesus Christ I thought
that all of that would be taken away
from my comedians I thought that that
was the the power of God and I don't
negate the fact that God could have done
that you know he could have taken all of
that away from my convenience but I
think what he wants more is exactly what
Kesey was talking about this intimacy
what he wants is he wants this this
dependence and to know that he loves me
and that he's willing to work out
whatever it takes if he would have taken
it away from my convenience poof I would
have thought oh I did that and so you
know it wouldn't have brought me closer
to God I would just would have probably
been one of these self righteous people
walking around
mm-hmm but the dirty air and the
filthier I saw myself in a situation
that I was in what it did is it helped
lead me to the fact that I really needed
a savior and and and in his word it says
that my strength is made perfect in your
weakness and then I had to be completely
naked and vulnerable and recognize just
how weak I was against this thing um
there were times when when I would just
feel too holy and I would act out and I
would come to God
you know defiant and and angry and
addicted and I would just say used to
want me you know cuz it's so much easier
to just go and act out and sin it's like
really you know you still want me as you
know your land for your [__] and his
answer was always the same even in my
defiance even in my misunderstanding of
his nature every other man had walked
out on me beginning with my dad the kids
in school did call me [__] queer and
little girl and then you know even in
the church culture and in the gay
culture you know I was so sexually
active that I allowed men to use me and
I would use them I had absolutely no
value of my own and I thought that no
man ever valued me either
but when Jesus responded to me and each
and every time as dirty and broken as I
was he said yeah Mike I'm in this I'm
still here for you I still want you
that's what broke through you know
because of living 20 years in the gay
culture and and again I hope that we
have compassion about people that we may
not have experienced on our own or that
kind of thing but to have compassion
about people that are in these
identities is like they didn't just
choose that or they didn't just you know
walk through that door and that was who
they were you know there's a series of
things that happen in their lives that
brought them there and I thought that
this really was who I was
and so God had to win back my heart he
had to show me through the example of
Jesus Christ that he was not only
long-suffering but patient and kind and
all of these wonderful things that even
if I chose to go back that his feelings
for me would not change I always thought
that God was disgusted with me I always
thought that God was just waiting to to
flick me in the head and to you know to
pull the rug out from under my salvation
so as I'm beginning this journey with
God after I was baptized it was really
difficult and I think that we would we
would do well to let people know that
you know what you're just beginning this
journey and and for as long as it's
going to take you know I'm committed to
you and and if we're examples of Jesus
Christ can I be patient enough to walk
with you Keisha until all of this is
over for you do you see the difference
in that yeah so it's not just about
having the truth it's gotta be the truth
and love combined so I want to go to
Isaiah chapter 4 in verse 1 and it says
in that day seven women shall take hold
of one man saying we will eat our own
bread and we're on our own apparel only
let us be called by thy name to take
away our reproach when somebody read
this to me is that this is the gay
community you know this is this is
really all about sin and so what is a
woman represent in the Bible oh very
good you guys are so smart are you
looking at my screen so anyway as we go
we're talking about these women that
want to take hold of one man it's a
church so these seven churches want to
take hold of one man so who's the one
man that the church holds on to Jesus
Christ absolutely and so here they want
a relationship with Jesus Christ and
they want his name so let's let's take
Christian as an example right so that's
the name that they want to be saved from
reproach and then they say but but
listen you know we're pretty independent
women or pretty independent churches and
we'll eat our own bread and so what does
bread represent
the Word of God thank you and then what
is a garment represent ranches nice
righteousness or righteousness right and
so here's seven churches and they want
Christ's name but they're not going to
follow the Word of God and they're not
going to wear the righteousness of
Christ they say we'll wear our own
garments and so isn't that a prefix
Christian isn't that the same and so you
can take whatever your identity is
whether it be LGBT you know a sexual
deviant or fornicator or you know
adulterer or whatever because the
biggest issue in the Christian church
it's not LGBT the biggest issue is
monogamous adultery you know so many
people young people are are having
sexual relationships beginning with
their exposure to pornography at 6 and 7
years old and then eventually leading up
like oh you know what we're in a
committed relationship we're gonna get
married what's the difference you know
we can have a sexual relationship even
though we're going to get married and
all of that is a breakdown of the
perfect blessing that God had designed
for each one of us through the
complementarianism of the male and the
female together and anything that the
devil can do to destroy that is of
course going to bring shame upon the
name of Jesus Christ so second Timothy 3
verse 5 it blares to me now he it
glaringly says or blaringly says it says
having a form of godliness but denying
the power thereof from such turn away
Wow
so now my eyes are open that there's a
group of people that are going to have a
form of godliness hmm but when you deny
the power of Jesus Christ
to change and transform your life mmm
from those people stay away why because
you know something if you would have
denied me the power of Jesus Christ to
transform my life and to not have the
last 20 years that I've had an it's been
it's been awful but it's also been
excellent
like the more that I have fallen into
the arms of Jesus Christ and recognized
that I needed his power and his victory
that he provided for me 2,000 years ago
if I wouldn't have been denied this and
mental Oh Mike just go back to your
boyfriend bring him to church with you
we love you
it's okay don't deny me the power Jesus
Christ to transform my life yeah and
from those people we are told to stay
away we need to be giving out to the
world something better than what the
world is handing out the world is
talking about behavior modification and
then they talk about all these forms of
therapy that are really destructive and
demonstrative to to us so look at this
look at this it talked about reparative
therapy and conversion therapy and some
people like to throw mud it coming out
ministries because they they really kind
of attack the theology but instead they
try to impugn our ministry by saying oh
they're all about conversion therapy and
reparative therapy but we're not none of
us have you none of us have those kind
of therapies and so that's about making
gay people straight our ministry isn't
about that at all I can't make a gay
person straight I couldn't make myself
straight but what I recognized that in
this ministry is that when you realize
that Christ's righteousness is available
for you no matter where you are that
that can transform you that can make
changes in your life and that's not a
bad thing that's not a hate message
that's a restoration message but you
can't get that in the world we're not
talking about behavior modification cuz
I could white-knuckle it and I could do
some of the modalities of reparative
therapy and you know maybe I could beat
a pillow and get rid of the anger from
my father or you know maybe maybe if a
man would hold me naked that maybe my
homosexual attractions would pass or
maybe could do electrotherapy you know
to me and that jumbled up my my brain
patterns but we're not talking about
that we're talking about a divine
restoration that's something you can't
get in this world and how sad that the
Christian community I believe is so
unaware of the possibilities and the
power of God that still exists today
that we have denied people that the
blood of Jesus has been shed for you
know to experience that and so that's
really what I think it's all about it's
about taking away the power of God to
transform into restore life so I want to
share with you a clip of a young woman a
Christian student that's at a Christian
university who's going to this group
that is LGBTQ affirming she also talks
about her time with coming up ministries
and the correlation of the two and the
determination or the under
that she got from that uh after I
decided that I don't want to have
anything to do with this lifestyle
anymore
I also decided that I'm going to stop
listening to those music watch those
movies are shows that are like elevating
the LGBTQ lifestyle because I felt like
those things were would take me back
because of course they they are emotion
they work with your emotions like hey
how do you remember how that felt in the
past like being in a relationship with a
woman so different all those memories
that you don't want to have because you
know that I know that they they would
pull me back into looking for for a
woman to find that comfort and find that
like identity with her since I'm I'm
studying counseling I'm very aware of
the things that I'm influenced you
through what you see what you hear and
everything that can come through those
places like yeah like the scripture said
by beholding we become change and I felt
like if I keep looking at the things I
would go back to where I was I was have
I was being in the communication with
coming out ministry and also I was going
to the group but um I made a vow with
Christ and I realized I mean this group
was good to me till one point but I
don't want to stay there I don't want to
stay at being affirmed personally I was
feeling that this was grooming me to go
back you know and it's nothing against
anyone in the group but it's not it's
not the environment that I was looking
for because I'm I had a person I had I
have a personal journey with Jesus and I
realized that it's not
help me I stayed with the communication
with coming out ministry because there's
where I found like Jesus too because we
were all focusing on Jesus you know so
everyone was going through their thing
through their problems through their
through their struggles with same-sex
attraction but we had we were focusing
on Jesus so we were not focusing on
ourselves and how we feel because Jesus
wants us to change he doesn't want us to
stay there it was me to change yeah I
kept in communication with coming out
ministry we had like the prayer on the
line and that was helping me a lot like
people would tell their experiences we
would support each other pray for each
other and I would feel good I would feel
affirmed in Christ not in not at me not
in them but affirm in Christ so like the
the scripture said by beholding we
become and I was beholding Jesus so I'm
not lingering on those things and I feel
such a peace that I have never felt
before in my life so when you see the
difference and and again I think that
the world has created this picture and
little light studios does a huge amount
of promoting this idea from the world
that it's like oh you know let your
heart decide let your let your mind
determine what your truth is and
Jeremiah 17:9 that says the mind is
deceitful above all things and
desperately wicked who can know it
and so I can't trust my mind to tell me
who I am
I need the Word of God in biology is
like your your fingerprint on the inside
to tell me who I am and so when I
thought as a little boy that had
rejected my father's examples that that
I only wanted to be like my mom I didn't
want to be like my dad and so that was
becoming my truth but it could have been
affirmed into my truth if I was
surrounded by
books that were telling me that it was
okay to go venture outside of what the
physical biology was telling me that it
was just it's as if when jesus healed
the lame man
and now he's walking he's healed but
then his friends away what are you doing
that's so comfy aren't you just come
back you know affirming his illness so
this is an amazing clip of a young man
well he's younger than me so he's a
young man but this is a guy that spent a
lot of time in Hollywood and he
identified his day and came out and he
was experiencing everything that
Hollywood had to offer he wanted to be
an actor or a director of producer the
event ended up being like a stage
designer and he was very good at what he
did he he knew a lot of Hollywood people
and would go to all these amazing
parties and it's amazing when you when
you hear his testimony about how how he
found God and I want to show that
I was at one of the after parties one
night and like everyone was dancing and
all the people the fashion world were
there and it was like very glamorous and
and I just remember just looking out
over the sea of people all having the
times of their lives and I just felt so
empty and dead inside I was like I felt
so alone and just empty
[Music]
and about I think six months later I was
at a coffee shop in Silver Lake we
noticed something very shocking the
table next to us had just Bibles all
over it and we were kind of fascinated
by it even though it was to us it was
like the enemy like those are the people
who hate who we are so he but we were
fascinated by them still so my friend
urged me to to talk to them and I said
well what does your church believe about
a sexuality and he said well you know
it's a sin and like I just stayed and I
was like huh okay that's interesting and
then we talked some more and then he
invited me to his church
somehow I just I don't even I got up the
Sunday morning and the pastor comes out
and he started preaching from Romans
chapter seven and then all of a sudden
the Holy Spirit just flooded me that's
when I saw the holiness of God and my
sinfulness at the same time it and I
just started bawling it was like this
mix of of joy and sorrow like sorrow
over my sin and joy over the fact that I
just met the king of the universe God
Jesus in that moment I knew that God was
real Jesus was real heaven was a real
hell was real eternal life was real the
Bible was real I hate just God was like
this is who I am this is who you are
you're now in my kingdom you're now my
child and we now are reconciled and we
have a relationship and I was like God
you have my whole life like this is it
it's all yours
when I was living that gay life in for
many many years I was a hundred percent
sure that was my identity like it was I
felt like I was born that way it was my
orientation it was my identity and I
felt like it was immutable and one of
the things that also happened during
that that moment of conversion was I
knew beyond a shadow of a doubt that
homosexuality was not who I was that my
identity was in Christ that that was not
who I was
[Music]
this is the issue the deal-breaker
homosexuality is the deal-breaker for
the LGBT community
when it comes to Christianity and I felt
the same way people always say well
isn't it unloving to say that
homosexuality is a sin and I'm like no
it's unloving to let people spend
eternity apart from God and that's
unloving I couldn't have said it that's
what a lot of people ask is they go well
how do i minister to my you know my gay
neighbor or my gay brother you know or
my sister and I hope it's not your job
to comfort them right God didn't ask you
to comfort them he said love them he
said you know create a safety net where
where they can come and they can find my
healing right we have to be profoundly
hospitable you know the gay community
has hospitality down cold
and if there's nobody else that can
compete better and we as Christians have
to be that loving example of what the
gospel really is you know I put up this
this this picture on the screen and it
says if you're using the Bible to hurt
other people you're using it wrong
and it shows an LGBT individual bleeding
and beaten by these preachers with the
Bible and you know it refers to Romans
13:10 is's love does no harm to its
neighbor therefore love is the
fulfillment of the law we need to be
offering people divine love not just
regular love that we have for each other
you know what about that verses says
that we need to love our enemies not
that the gay community is our enemy I
think sometimes we ourselves are our own
worst enemy because we think that by
telling someone the truth that they're
just gonna magically you know come back
and and and put away and denounce all of
these things in their life but we need
to let them know however long it takes
that this is an environment where we can
create love and acceptance where they
are and to allow the Holy Spirit to take
them to the next dimension and the Holy
Spirit did that for me it took some time
it took several years to be able to
address not only the sexual addiction
but the history and the memory and then
to have that kind of support and love to
know that if I have a bad day there are
you still going to be willing to love me
and accept me you know into the fold
until I find that victory that I seek I
believe that's what the church can
really be I want to segue a little bit
you know because we've talked about the
damage of what the LGBT issue is going
to do to the church and the whole idea
of taking out Christianity that's
according to the Bible but people ask us
they go you know how can the church be a
safe place you know for LGBTQ people but
at what point would somebody be ready
for membership or leadership in the
church I believe that we need to be like
a hospital then I put up the slide you
know if we you you do a comparison
between a hospital and a church and
they're very similar you know a hospital
is filled with health professionals but
also those people that are sick and so
the hospital is there to provide
something for people from the community
right so what would happen if if the
hospital were filled with health
professionals but nobody from the
community what would happen they would
go under it would shut down there'd be
no use for it really right so the same
thing with the church if the church had
its doors closed to only the Saints or
the people that were the health
professionals in the church
there'd be no reason for a church to
exist right a church should be the same
as that Hospital is that you're not
ready for membership or leadership until
you've gone the full way and you've
studied and you you recognize in your
mind that the Bible is the is the the
text book right to make you that health
professional and if you're not ready
that's okay stay here right let's say
you do Bible studies with a gay couple
and they have three kids you're asking
this couple to not only break up their
relationship but divide the kids divide
a household that may take some time but
in the process of doing Bible studies
with them and opening up your home on
Sunday night and feeding them and
celebrating with them and establishing
relationships with them then when
they're to that point when the
we spirit convicts them they'll know
exactly what to do and then as they make
that that changed what does the Bible
say showing me for repentance meaning
showing changes in their life that
they're ready to be baptized then
they're ready to be members of the
church and I believe that that's a
beautiful illustration of what the
church should be we don't have to be
afraid of allowing people into the
church that aren't like us or that come
from different backgrounds than us but
we have to be able to let them know that
they matter that they belong and that
they're loved in our churches but again
we're not ready to move them to
membership until they're fully convinced
that this is what they want so that when
they go through the baptism that they're
ready to have a vote and an influence in
the church to make sure this is what
they want which means don't hold
information okay so a beautiful story I
have a beautiful story about that there
was a girl that was doing Bible studies
with a gay male couple in her living
room every Friday night for two years
Wow for two years she was doing these
Bible studies but she never talked about
the case she didn't dungeon but after
two years these guys they loved Jesus
they loved the Sabbath they loved the
state of the Dead they were they were on
board they were like we want to get
baptized and she's like ah and and they
said well what does the Bible say about
homosexuality and she goes give me some
time I'll get back with you on that so
they gave her a couple of weeks and she
called me and she said what do I do
and she said I love them they're part of
my family they've been in my living room
every Friday night for two years and she
said I don't want to do anything to hurt
them that's why I've never you know
addressed this topic and so I was
thinking of myself and I go well what
would be the best you know does she
search it all out and then give that to
them and then I thought well well then
they're just basically accepting her
opinions and I said wait a minute I said
the Holy Spirit's been working for the
last two years he's first been moving
them I said why don't you that the Holy
Spirit tell them I said instead of you
getting the the information and they're
giving him back to them why don't you
discover it together just as you have
been for the last two years on Friday
night so she agreed to do that and as
they open up the word of God the next
Friday and she said you know we're
asking for the Holy Spirit's guidance
and I know that the Holy Spirit will
lead us and then she opened up the
scriptures of Leviticus and Romans and
Jude and first Corinthians
each and every time that that she went
over those passages these guys were like
oh my oh my you know what she pointed
out that they were not an abomination to
God but that the behavior drove a wedge
between the intimacy that God wanted
with each one of us and you know what
she left them with a very difficult
decision but there was no doubt in their
mind that she loved them no doubt in
their mind that she she was there for
them and that she did not want to hurt
them I thought that was really powerful
yes so Christ method alone will give
true success in reaching people first of
all he meets them where they are and you
know what I think that that goes as far
as a transgender person that insists
that you call it if it's a guy to a girl
and he wants to be called Elizabeth and
you know call him Elizabeth if that
keeps the door open so that you have
access to him and to love him and to
show that person that you know that that
you can stay connected to them because
Jesus met me where I was right he's
young sure did so so in that process you
know meeting them where they are showing
sympathy for them showing empathy you
know that you understand or maybe you
don't understand but there was a
transgender person in Belgium and I
remember thinking to myself oh I got
this all wrapped up I come from that I
know exactly how to deal with this
and so I I look at this person and it's
a man that they became a female he had
the top and the bottom surgery done but
he was six foot five any of these
massive hands you know and and there's
this huge brow line I mean he he still
looked unfortunately like a man with
bumps and so as I was in the church he
was married he had children his wife
divorced him his children wouldn't talk
to him the church treated him like a
pariah they just left him alone they
didn't know how to deal with him and I
realized that everything that I had
prepared was was not the right thing to
do and the Lord impressed me just to
keep my mouth shut and the only thing I
could do was listen to him the only
thing that was really going to matter
that day is that he needed someone he
need to know that somebody was willing
to just sit beside him that wasn't
ashamed of him and had just listened to
to the fact that he was in great pain
from the surgery the the scarring of the
tissue and stuff left him with with pain
chronic
and what he was going through with this
church and his family and you know what
even that in itself has got to be
powerful so not only did he showed
sympathy to them he ministered to their
needs you know if anyone their
confidence that takes time it's not a
microwave gospel you know we can't just
set it on two minutes and ding there's
the gospel do you accept it you know we
have to be patient and loving into to
wait for them to know as a matter of
fact let me use this this cracked me up
and I was looking at my pastor like
what's the matter with you you know
there were friends of mine that have
been friends of mine for about seven
eight years and they were now taking
Bible studies the pastor comes over and
he's got it all worked out he's gonna
he's going to show them you know the
truth of the Bible and he went through
Boom Boom Boom Boom and goes there any
questions ago no we really don't have
any questions great when can I schedule
your baptism because now that there's no
questions you're ready to be baptized
really whoa whoa
you know we need some time what by
anytime
I just showed you you don't have
anything you know to counter that with
I've just proven it to you from the Word
of God you should be ready that's not
the gospel you know it's not that so
don't we have to allow the Holy Spirit
to water that soul right and to let that
precious moisture get to the roots
mm-hmm but my church was able to do that
for me this this little black church it
was in my community the for lack of a
better word the white church in my
community I didn't feel the love I the
pastor couldn't even shake my hand the
pastor would avoid eye contact with me
but eventually I moved to this this
little black church in my community and
the head elder was this this man that
worked in a factory that was a drug
addict and he had accepted the Lord as
his Savior and it only had about 12 12
members and most of them were his family
members that were baptized with him so I
asked him I said do you have any room in
your church for an acts homosexual xxxx
addict me said well have a seat with all
the other sinners in can you preach
every now and then because we don't have
a regular preacher Mike what and any and
so I started going to this church and at
the first foot washing but the first
voice wap4 push one but fight at the
firt and I'll leave it in it's kind of
funny sorry at the first foot washing
this this guy I brought a one-legged guy
his name
Willie and I had gotten to know Willie
he would hobble to the to the store to
get food and he had lost his leg in a in
a in a in a drug bust or whatever and so
he didn't have went running water in his
house so I would take him to my house I
give him a bath I'd shave his face I cut
his hair I'd make him a hot meal
and I would just talk to him about how
good god was and I invited him to my
church and he came so we had foot
washing on the Sabbath it came and I
thought great I get 50% off foot washing
yeah one foot but anyway after I was
done this man insisted that he wash my
feet and now I thought while I'm with
Willie and he said no I insist let me
serve you and that man didn't know how
to heal somebody like me you know and
and I was so used to not you know giving
men hugs or whatever for fear that they
would feel like I was copping a fuel or
something and so but that guy insisted
Ennis all right i sat down and he wasn't
afraid to touch my feet like he humbled
himself and he was washing my feet and
as he was kneeling in front of me he
started to say wow Mike I love you
enthusiasm for Jesus what a difference
you've made in our church and you know
just those words coming at me that was
bringing healing to me and then as he
started to pray for me and there were
only like three or four other men in
that room but each one of those men were
moved by the Holy Spirit the Holy Spirit
said get up and touch it nobody does
that
right but these four men they came over
to me and they just put their hand on my
shoulder and as they put their hands on
my shoulder I realized for the first
time that I was part of the men's club
and not part of the ladies lunch club
anymore and that was being included by
the men and I was being loved by the men
and that in itself was so healing for me
and Ecclesiastes 4:10 I think really
sums it up what our churches really
should be and it says for if they follow
the one will lift up his fellow but woe
to the one who is alone when he falls
for yes know when to help in mob you
know what that's what our churches are
filled with you know I remember you know
being in a bar when I did a gay bar Russ
shortly after I'd become a Christian and
I remember that everybody was getting
their drinks and then they were they
were talking about you know their
religion and how their religion had
rejected them or how their religion had
either ignored them or pushed them out
of the church end and here we sat around
there and I
realize that the only place that we
really could commune and share about God
was in a gay bar Wow well because the
church wasn't able to provide that for
us and I think that the church has
really lost precious time in dealing
with this issue and recognizing that
that the the mercy or the the gospel of
Jesus Christ has to be available for
everyone otherwise for no one I want to
share with you another incredible story
I put up on the screen this is the the
pasadena church that was in pasadena
california and that's a picture of one
of my colleagues wayne Blakely and also
a guy in the middle his name is Greg so
we had just recently met Greg we had we
done the premiere of our movie journey
interrupted and you can download a copy
of it for free from our website but it
was the first time that we shown it and
I got into a phone conversation with
Greg and he was actually a member of
kinship and he had been on their board
and that was the gay affirming
seventh-day adventists group and so he'd
been having these dreams these
reoccurring dreams and and he started to
study the Bible again and he was
realizing that God was calling him out
of his gay life he was in a marriage
with another man and he was a successful
businessman but he called me and he said
so tell me about your conversion I'm
like really you know there's 47 youtube
videos out there you can go to our
website but the Lord said like just be
patient and take your time so I remember
just sitting down and an hour and a half
later I just gave it all to him you want
it here you know and I gave him every
ugly detail of it
and he appreciate he said I really
appreciate that you didn't candy-coat it
or make it sound real nice and I and I
said I really appreciate the struggle I
said well honestly that that's what it's
been like and he said you know I'm just
not sure if this is real or not and I
said you know what you should come and
check out our movie then you know meet
us and we were all going to be in
Michigan together so he did he came in
met us and he saw a movie not once but
twice and on that Sunday afternoon after
the second time the guy was sobbing and
you know it was like the big cry and and
he said I realize now that I have to
make some very important decisions you
know about his living arrangement as
well as you know his identity and stuff
so we were invited to come to the
pasadena church and the pro-life I'm
sorry the pro-lgbt grew
that's within the denomination called
the gay community when they found out
that we were presenting there and they
said listen you got to stop this you
know these presentations these people
are reparative therapists and you know
they're here to to damage the gay
community and to cause people to commit
suicide so of course the LGBT community
got up in arms and I didn't know this
but in Pasadena they have the largest
per capita LGBT population yes yeah yeah
yeah
per capita right so here we are in this
huge area and we're going to be speaking
so the night before our presentations we
were actually on the news they found out
the news cameras all because this this
probe gay movement in our contamination
said hey look at these guys you want to
get them out so they came and they
objectively filmed you know awesomely we
talked about what we were planning to
address the next day and I remember the
next morning we had talked a little bit
about you know if we were ever picketed
wouldn't it be nice to hand out water to
the protesters and you know if it was
raining to give them umbrellas
you know rainbow umbrellas and and to
basically let them know that you know
what we understand we're not against you
right and so um let me tell you this
church they bumped it up to a higher
notch and I didn't know if we were gonna
get arrested I didn't know if we were
gonna be attacked and I remember the
next morning holding up my ties thinking
you know what tie do you wear if you're
gonna go to jail you know red one or the
blue one so we got to the church that
morning and sure enough the protesters
were organizing but the these little
Filipino ladies they were like 70 years
old and they're in their little you know
church outfits and they go running out
to the protesters you know with the
rainbow Mohawks and stuff and they go
listen if you get really hungry we've
got some doughnuts for you and some hot
chocolate we have to see you know come
inside if you want to listen to the
presentations you can you know and
they're like what and they buy these
sweet little old ladies coming at them
so then what they did is they were out
there holding up signs that if you love
honk so while we're doing presentations
inside the church you can hear the
honking but it's just a reminder that
there are people outside that just don't
know the love of Jesus right and so when
lunchtime came after the divine service
these little ladies went out to the
Gruben they say hey listen we've made
you haystacks right Adventist ghetto
food
you made your haystacks and they said
come inside and eat and this one guy he
was holding up a flag and he said I
can't go in and eat my job is to hold
this flag mmm and the pastor waiting
three guns take a look at this
the pastor went up to the guy and he
said listen let me hold your flag while
you come in and eat the flag for you so
there's a picture of the pastor actually
holding the flag while the protester was
inside eating and shows some of the
protesters out there but look at this
comment on the screen look at this
comment that somebody wrote down on the
comment section for the churches says
thank you for being polite to us it
wasn't that beautiful so there was
another comment that was made on
somebody's Facebook that was also one of
the protesters and the head elder went
out there with his family had two
darling little girls and his wife and
they went out and this is what the man
said he said this beautiful family came
out of the church to make sure that we
knew that they loved the LGBT community
and that they loved us they invited us
to eat lunch with them and even offered
to hold our signs on the street while we
ate what an amazing display of true
Christian spirit we need to be mindful
that it's not a bait and switch you know
winning people's confidence to trick
them into Jesus you're winning their
confidence to show them true love and in
order to do that before you even go and
start mingling with people here you to
work on yourself yeah you're right and
your attitude is right so then you can
win people's confidence and bring them
directly to Jesus Christ well thank you
candy yeah so I want to tell you another
story that I think is it's really
precious it's really powerful one of the
tracks that we hand out to people
talking about our ministry it has a
story inside it called the biscuit story
and it's actually about one of the
mothers that comes on our prayer line
that's praying for a daughter that's gay
and she called me one time and she said
my daughter wants to know if she can
bring her girlfriend over to the house
and she said I do not want that woman in
my house I don't want to see them you
know giving affection to each other I
don't want them sleeping in the same
room and she said I just don't want her
here I want my daughter to come home but
I don't want that other woman and I
reminded her I said well you remember
that Jesus died for the other woman too
because I know I know
and she said I'm convicted and I'm gonna
have to pray about it but I really don't
want her here and so I suggested you
know you could put up some you know some
house rules you know no PDA and that
they have to sleep in separate rooms it
is your house and and she felt that you
know she wanted a godly home and
represented that way and so she she
prayed about it and she called her
daughter and she said okay you can bring
her but these are the conditions and her
daughter said fine I'll respect your
home so she comes to her house and the
morning they wake up and and and the
daughter says to her mom she goes mom
will you make biscuits and gravy and her
mom didn't she goes that's a lot of work
she goes but I'm happy to do it if
you'll help me and her daughter said
sure mom you know I'll make the gravy
but the other girl you know she's like
uh I don't cook and my mother never took
the time to teach me to cook she goes I
don't know anything about the kitchen
and and this mother who was an excellent
teacher anyway and saw the opportunity
and I believed was was channeling the
Holy Spirit she had she had addressed
her own issues or whatever and she said
to the girl she goes listen come over
here I'll help you make the biscuits
we'll make up together and so they
worked that morning and they made the
biscuits and they had a nice meal and
then afterwards the the two girls went
out and she was showing um this girl her
mother's farm her parents farm and as
they were going through the farm and
they ended up in the garage or the barn
and as they're in the barn this girl
broke down and she started sobbing and
her friend said what did my mother say
to you my mother said something to
offend you and while she's crying and
she's trying to stop crying so that she
can speak and finally when she gets some
clarity she said I can't believe your
mother she goes why and she said I know
what your mom thinks about us and she
said my mother wouldn't even take the
time to teach me how to cook and she
said and as much as your mother dislikes
our relationship she said I can't
believe how kind she was and that she
actually showed me how to make the
biscuits hmm it didn't stop there and we
use that story in in this in this little
booklet and I wish we had the the time
to tell the rest of the story because a
year and a half ago a year and a half
ago that girl called my friend who's
been on our prayer line praying for a
daughter and she said I want to thank
you for your prayers for me and I know
you've been praying for me and she said
I have walked out of the gay life
I realized that this is not what God
wants for me I've given up the drugs and
the alcohol and the women and she said
and now I'm walking with Jesus Christ
and I want to thank you for those
prayers mmm that's something it's the
gospel that's the that's the stuff I
can't get enough of you know that's
that's the stuff that makes all of this
worthwhile it's not about now you know
browbeating people into a relationship
and I like that it's not about this
bait-and-switch is like oh you're come
and take this I don't quit you know look
it's Jesus it's not the same yeah you
can get that off of coming out
ministries website if coming out
ministries org it's just one of our
tracks and it's a track talking about
the ministry and it has the biscuit
story in it as well each one of us has a
track Kezia has hers my other colleagues
Wayne I'm sorry Ron Woolsey and Harrison
pneumoniae and myself as well and we
have more resources coming out as well
we have a couple new ones that are
coming out talking about navigating life
storms talking about how is it that we
can go through the storm of life you
know with the LGBT thing and all these
things that are coming out at us and and
Ron Woolsey who is a pilot himself he
talks about the tail winds and the head
winds and how to make a safe landing
right into the arms of Jesus which i
think is is brilliant but Ron also has
two other books that are out he has his
testimony called that kind can never
change Ken they basically talking about
a pastor that told his wife you know
when when she was sharing that her
husband is same-sex attracted he said
that kind can't change you should just
get a divorce so Ron's second book is
also called straight answers to the gay
questions and it's 20 years of you know
internet question and answers that he's
compiled together into a resource which
is I think amazing I also have DVDs we
have the gay puzzle one into that that
are 49 30 minute
you know recordings talking about
everything from masturbation to
pornography and homophobia in the church
and Canha gay be born again and rewiring
same-sex you know same-sex talking about
you know repairing male to male
ships like with some of the men that are
in my church so it's amazing some of the
resources that we have available in
their moment they are so let me close
with this last story because I think
it's brilliant if I may and and I'm
gonna put up the the pictures because
they're just so beautiful so we talked
about you know one of the things that
you need to do especially since the gay
community knows so much about
hospitality you got to make sure you do
it right it's ok let's say that you have
a gay neighbor right so you don't just
let the heads grow up so high that you
can't see they're coming and going you
know and then you know with the heads
the way it is that you come out and you
know you're working in the yard or
you're playing ball with your son and
then all of a sudden your gay neighbors
come home you don't just run into the
house and shut and lock the door and
close the blinds instead instead what we
we talk about doing is basically making
up your table you know making a nice
meal setting the table put some flowers
on there because that really adds a lot
to you know a gay couple or to the gay
community and then going over to the
house and knocking on the door and
inviting your neighbors over for dinner
and so if they agree and you know
they're willing to come over you know
then you invite them in you have a good
time you you you serve them a really
nice meal you know put on the hog you
know make sure that you do it up nice
and and don't put your Bible at the end
of the table do not put your Bible at
the end of the table it's not about
having this Bible study about how their
lives are wicked or whatever it's about
creating those relationships it's about
those those four steps right meeting
people where they are
so as you establish that relationship
and you you learn more about them or
whatever then they go on to their way or
whatever and then two weeks later you
set the table again and you go over and
you knock on their door again and invite
him again and it's about creating a
relationship and friendship you know and
each and every time they come over it
and then eventually maybe one day they
would say to you they go what does your
church think about a homosexuality you
know and give them an opportunity
doesn't your church hate people like us
and how wonderful to say have we
demonstrated hate to you and you know
what the Bible has nothing but love
towards everyone you know and beginning
that that discussion but you know don't
bash them over the head with you know
with what the Bible is saying don't
condemn them don't make them feel
condemned but really when you stop and
think about it all have sinned and come
short of the glory of God listen I'm no
better than you seen at the end of the
day
every one of us are on this table and
everybody watching this is really all
dealing with an identity crisis mm-hmm
and that's who we are in Christ you know
one sin entered the world that's what we
were struggling with is is who are we
now you know because that relationship
was broken and it's only in the
restoration of that relationship that we
find out who we really are
yeah yeah I love what the Bible says in
its second Corinthians 5:17 it says
therefore if anyone is in Christ he is a
new creation old things have passed away
behold all things have become new
mmm-hmm that promise is for every single
one of us no matter what our
circumstances are well no matter what
we're going through mm-hmm yeah that's
exactly my eyes have been open even to
Keyes news story even though we've
worked together for over a year now when
when you talk about how your identity
related to your race and I didn't even
get that I didn't even relate to that
because I knew that you ended up with
with by sexual attraction but I didn't
realize the damage of what happened even
for you misunderstanding or not being
able to kind of put together that you
had an Asian mother and a black father
and and how to get that identity to come
together especially when you didn't look
like your mom like that's an identity
crisis as well whereas mine was I
thought that I was a girl trapped in a
boy's body two completely different
issues but yet they still come together
and exactly what you said Keith we are
all struggling with an identity issue
photos Marilyn Manson see make sure you
stick around for led live patreon post
show we've got some extra content coming
your way it's a special content just for
our donors so if you don't know about
patreon makes you go to
patreon.com/scishow studios you can see
all our perks and rewards on there and
catch that extra content we're putting
out every single week we will see you on
patreon thank you Michael and Kezia for
all that insight and how we can react to
the world around us and specifically at
the church
you know as I think about this topic you
know I just go back to the fact like
we've all been talking about we're all
dealing with some kind of identity
crisis what is your identity crisis it's
time for you to think about that now and
as you watch this video you know we want
to hear your comments we want to hear
what you have been going through we want
to hear your questions send those to us
in the comments below and remember you
you are a new creation in Christ and he
wants to make your whole life news so if
you are dealing with anything go to him
and he can make it new thanks for
watching and we will see you next time
on LED live
[Music]